So now we're ready for a quiz to see if you understand nested lists.
For this quiz, you're given a variable named "countries,"
and it's defined with a list of information about some of my favorite countries.
And for each country, there's a list containing 3 things:
the name of the country, the capital, and its population in millions.
I should point out, of course, for those of you in Romania or in smaller countries,
that when it comes to countries, bigger is not always better.
First, try to write code that will print out the capital of India.
We can find India as the second country in our countries list.
And the capital is the second element of that list.
You obviously could solve this by just printing out "Delhi."
I don't want you to solve it that way.
I want you to solve it by finding an expression that uses the countries variable
to find the right value.